[ YouTube Learning ]
Now that you have created a class
on Google Classroom,
let’s see how we can use Google Meet
to conduct a Live class!
[ Don't Memorise intro music ]
The best way to conduct a Live Class,
for your students is by using Google Meet
for which you need to generate a link!
How do we do that?
You can simply generate the Meet link by clicking here!
There you go, you have your meet link now!
You can choose to make the link visible to
students immediately,
or even on the day of your live class.
But there’s something really important you need to know
about Google Meet when you generate the link like this.
As a teacher,
you have complete control over your live class.
The students can enter the Google Meet class
only after you have joined the class
and can see who all have joined.
You can add or remove any of your students.
You can choose to put them on mute
if there’s disturbance.
And the class ends, only after you decide to end it.
Isn’t that amazing?
But remember, that all this will be possible
only if you generate the meet link by clicking here.
If you generate the Meet link using the calendar
or the app directly, these features may or may not work.
And Google Meet is also a very safe platform to use,
as nobody can attend your live online class
without your approval.
Moreover, Google Meet works  on
smartphones, laptops, and tablets as well.
Now that you know this,
let’s find out what all you could do using Google Meet?
This is how your Google Meet screen would look.
You can look at the list of your students
by clicking here.
And these two buttons can be used to
switch your camera and mic on or off.
One of the most important things you can do
is teach using a presentation you have already created.
You could do this by Sharing your Screen.
All you have to do is click on the
‘Present Now’ button,
and share the tab in which your presentation is open.
Imagine how amazing it would be for the students
to view your beautiful presentation
while they are listening to you.
It could easily help the students make notes,
and also visualise better.
And guess what;
your students could also share their screens
if they want to share their work with the entire class.
Let’s stop this presentation now.
Alternatively, it could be a talking face live session
where the students can just see you on the screen.
You also have the option to hear and see
all your students on your screen.
I know you’d really like that but you should
know that it would consume more bandwidth,
and hence it’s better that your students
are all on mute and have their camera disabled.
But do you know how your students could still feel
involved in your session?
Yes, the chat feature.
They can always ask questions, and post their thoughts
using the Chat option they see here.
And as a teacher,
you can answer them whenever you feel like;
either immediately, or at the end of your session
And there are two more amazing features
of Google Meet that would help us teachers.
Did you know that you could also record your session?
Yes, by clicking on the Record Meeting button here,
your entire session could be recorded and then
shared with the students that missed your session!
Isn’t that amazing?
And now for one more super interesting feature!
If you turn on the Captions button here,
Meet automatically types out what you say
and shows it to your students.
This could not only help students
who missed out on what you said
but also help students with hearing impairments.
I know you must be waiting to get started.
In the upcoming videos,
I will talk about how you could share content and create
assignments for your students in Google Classroom
See you there!
[ #TeachFromAnywhere ]
[ YouTube Learning ]